stretching way back to my childhood I
wanted to understand time being shown
the stars through a telescope and told
that you know what I was seeing was
thousands of years in the past to me
it's a mystery that the absent flows of
time my name is gem finer and I'm
composed long-player
which is a an everlasting piece of
releasing the repeats every thousand
years long Clair started playing at the
beginning of the year 2000 around the
middle of the 1990s the millennium
started to be discussed a lot but really
all that was being discussed were very
short ways of celebrating a few nights
of fireworks and parties
it seemed to me there's a kind of
absurdity about celebrating something so
long by strategies that were so sure so
one of the things that interested me is
making this thousand is tangible it
occurred to me one day that the best way
I could do that was to write a piece of
music
if you imagine taking six copies of the
same record and playing them on six
different turntables these spinach
turntable at different speed you're
moving through the material at different
points on each one and in that way you
get a relationship that never resolves
never comes back into phase until
exactly after a thousand years so what
these singing bowls are here are all the
bowls that are necessary to play any
point of long-player in its
thousand-year long duration you think
singing always just this bow it you just
take it and it sounds but actually is a
very complex
slightly all sorts of sounds in there
that you can tease out in different ways
the future of long-player could go many
different ways you don't know what's
going to happen
technologically politically culturally
ecologically it creates this continuum
of people a community of listeners and
caretakers across generations until the
31st of December 2999 at which point it
will get back to where first up and
start again
[Music]